[Music]  [Music]  the first time I really took a horse in  the water I had a friend that had horses  on the north coast her house is right on  the beach we set up some little jumps  and we were going over with her horse  and she said oh it's too hot it's too  hot we've got to take the horse in the  water so we can't take the horse in the  sea like that  she said yeah sure come on jump on  [Music]  you know the waves are coming in and the  horse just sort of lifted his head and  the waves have come over and we just  went in a little bit deeper and a little  bit deeper and then he started swimming  [Music]  you can write all your life and you've  never felt that smoothness that that  power but with no there was no jolt at  all it was just so absolutely like silk  [Music]